[Música]
minha paixão pelo esporte começou quando
era garoto
eu jogava bola no quintal de casa todas
as estadas e conforme fui pegando
confiança pedir pro meu pai me inscrever
um campeonato
eu me lembro do dia em que eu entrei
para o quadro de artilheiros e foi
escalado para a seleção do clube aquilo
era o máximo para o menino naquela idade
saltando no tempo quando eu estava no
cursinho pré vestibular
eu passei por um assalto onde eu levei
um tiro e isso gerou a imobilidade
abaixo dos ombros
chamada de tetraplegia eu fui obrigado a
abandonar os estudos e dedicar todo meu
tempo a diversos tipos de fisioterapia
mas tive apoio incondicional da minha
família e dos meus amigos
em nenhum momento me faltou ajuda e
conforme eu fui conhecendo o universo
das clínicas de reabilitação e percebi
que era uma exceção
a maioria das pessoas que passam por
acidentes ou que nascem com deficiências
enfrenta também miséria
eu lembro do sofrimento de uma família
que não tinha como pagar o tratamento de
um filho que tinha nascido com paralisia
cerebral e aquilo começou a me incomodar
muito
o triste é que muita gente ainda passa
por isso e qual é o tamanho desse
público hoje no mundo
de acordo com a organização mundial de
saúde 15% da população do planeta têm
alguma deficiência
a gente está falando então de um bilhão
de pessoas no mundo e de 30 milhões no
brasil e quando a gente se debrucem
estudos que tratam da desigualdade
a gente percebe que esse é o segmento
que ainda enfrenta os mais graves níveis
de desigualdade e discriminação
o que a gente como a sociedade pode
fazer para romper com esse cenário já
estava começando com um amigo ea gente
comentava que talvez mais importante do
que falar sobre má distribuição de renda
no mundo é falar sobre maio a
instituição de educação no mundo
ou seja a gente não vai chegar muito
longe
enquanto toda a pessoa não tiver a
chance de estudar ter acesso ao
conhecimento acesso ao mercado de
trabalho e acesso à dignidade
isso vale também para as pessoas com
deficiência
esse é o propósito tem orientado a minha
vida eu fundei um instituto que tem como
missão colaborar para que cada criança e
adolescente com deficiência têm a chance
de alcançar o seu melhor como ser humano
alcançar a autonomia através da educação
e foi por conta desse propósito que eu
voltei me aproximar do universo do
esporte
alguns anos o unicef me procurou para
que a gente criasse juntos um projeto
eles queriam aproveitar o momento da
copa e das olimpíadas no brasil para
estimular as escolas a explorar em
educação física de uma maneira diferente
não mais pautada pela competição mas
pautada pela inclusão e com isso a gente
criou um curso que tem sido freqüentado
por professores de todo o brasil
cada participante assumir o compromisso
de bhola aulas que viabilizem a
participação ea diversão de todo
estudante no final do processo a gente
visita a cada cidade para conhecer de
perto as histórias já são centenas de
transformações que merecem ser contadas
em uma viagem para natal por exemplo eu
conhecia maria luiza uma lua que tinha
12 anos estava cursando quinto ano de
uma escola pública
é a maria tinha um transtorno importante
ela nunca tinha falado mal interagir com
as pessoas e nem aceitava a merenda na
escola
a partir desse projeto os professores
pediram pra maria e para seus colegas de
classe
pensar em uma atividade que fosse
inclusiva e aí para surpresa geral
pela primeira vez ela falou deu sua
opinião e ajudou o grupo a criar uma
nova versão do badminton é uma espécie
de mistura entre o vôlei eo tênis
o que eles fizeram de tão diferente
11 11 o juiz passou a usar uma
sinalização visual para que os alunos
surdos intendência que estava
acontecendo
2 eles alteraram a duração do jogo para
que os alunos com autismo mantivesse a
sua concentração e 3
a quadra foi redimensionada para
facilitar a mobilidade dos cadeirantes e
por conta desse projeto é muito da
escola que antes era padronizado e
pautado pela mobilização hoje é um
ambiente de diversidade do ambiente
pensando assim goulart idade o melhor de
tudo é que a maria acabou como silêncio
angustiante de muitos anos
esse projeto é um exemplo concreto de um
legado positivo deixado pelos
megaeventos nosso país por conta dele e
acabei me envolvendo bastante como as
olimpíadas do rio
tive a alegria de conduzir a tocha e no
ano passado eu fui para o japão a
convite do fórum econômico mundial para
participar de um seminário
o objetivo era discutir como que as
próximas olimpíadas podem ampliar o seu
impacto social no final do debate
a mediadora perguntou a rodrigo
o que você acha que tóquio pode mudar
sentido em 2020
resumindo a minha resposta eu acho que a
separação completa dos jogos entre
olímpicos e paralímpicos vai na
contramão da idéia de uma sociedade
inclusiva que tipo de mensagem
que tipo de mensagem
a gente manda pro mundo segregando
alguns atletas pelo fato deles terem ou
não uma deficiência
além disso o ato a gente a pagar a pira
olímpica e depois de algumas semanas
acender a pira paralímpica só reforça
essa mensagem negativa
existe uma convenção da onu assinada por
mais de 100 países que condena a
separação das pessoas em virtude das
suas diferenças
pensando que as olimpíadas são um evento
do mundo e que suas cerimônias são
vitrines para bilhões de pessoas
eu gostaria de fazer uma proposta para
tóquio
mudanças da história
pedem símbolos
[Música]
proponho então em tóquio
a gente usa a mesma tocha a mesma pira é
o mais importante
a gente mantém acesa a chama de hoje
só assim a chama olímpica vai avançar a
magnitude do seu papel é representar a
igualdade dos seres humanos
obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]